hello we're glad you joined us for this
live webinar genom first a new paradigm
for the return of genomic results I am
Christina mahalik elaborate and I'll be
moderating the session today's
educational web seminar is presented by
labyrinth the leading scientific social
networking website and for later a
virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning to
learn more visit labrys com let's get
started you can post questions to the
speaker during the presentation while
they're fresh in your mind to do so
simply type them in the Q&A box which
will open when you click the green a Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window questions will be
answered after the presentation to
enlarge the side window click on the
screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of this slide window if you
experience technical problems seeing or
hearing the presentation just click on
the support button sounds as a pal right
of the presentation window or report
your problem by clicking on the green
Q&A fun at the lower left of the screen
this is an educational webinar and this
offers free continuing education credits
after the webinar is over please click
on this PE button located in the bottom
left hand corner of your web page and
follow the process of obtaining your
credit I am delighted to present today's
speaker Mark Williams within the
professor director genomic medicine
institute geisinger Health System dr.
Williams interest heaven to study the
impact of implementing genetics genomics
in family history in routine clinical
care successful implementation requires
the application of many design faris
elements including technology assessment
modeling in decision analysis the
science of behavior
change quality improvement knowledge
management informatics health care
economics and patient-centered outcomes
all of which are components of the
emerging discipline of implementation
science dr. Williams is also interested
in defining the value proposition of new
genomic technologies with value
beginning simplistically represented as
outcomes costs his research to date has
examined the impact a family history on
provider experience the role of inflam
attics to provide point of care just in
time education resources and passes
decision support to clinicians regarding
genetic topics impact of tumor based
screening of Lynch syndrome including
extensive modeling to optimize the
efficiency of the program to use a query
tool to obtain information on genetic
conditions from electronic data
warehouses in application of the tools
of quality improvements to facilitate
implementation of evidence-based best
practices in genetics in genetics dr.
Williams is beginning to explore how we
can get information from patients about
their preferences including an
assessment of patient locations on the
state of change continuum in the use of
those preferences to reconcile
priorities regarding preventive and
therapeutic intervention intervention
with the patient provider to see if that
will improve satisfaction for both and
increase compliance with recommendations
leading to measurable improvements in
outcomes and improve value once again I
am delighted to introduce today's
speaker dr. Williams you may now begin
your presentation
thank you very much for that very nice
introduction and for the opportunity to
present a seminar today as mentioned
we're going to be talking about a new
paradigm in genomics but before I get
into that I wanted to personalize this
presentation a bit and talk about a face
of our program this is a 53-year old
woman who was enrolled in our my code
Community Health Initiative she had a
history of basal cell carcinoma removed
at age 33 she is currently undergoing
treatment for Crohn's disease she has
received regular medical care but has
declined mammography for the last five
years she is the primary caregiver for
grandchildren so we're going to come
back to this face at the end of the
presentation to talk about the impact
that this can have on an individual so
as an overview for today's talk I'm
going to briefly discuss terms that are
in current use and reflect a bit of the
philosophic approach to precision
medicine that we're trying to implement
here at geisinger i also want to spend a
little bit of time discussing the
construct for assessing value in in
health care so this is something that is
becoming increasingly important and it's
not something that we're exposed to very
much I do apologize i know that there
are global attendees for this seminar
this will have a us-centric approach
however I think the concept of value is
international I am going to introduce
the genome first concept and then
present some data from our return the
results program and frame that within
the value construct there are a number
of different words or terms that have
been used to describe some of the
emerging technologies in practice
including genomic medicine personalized
medicine individualized medicine and
precision medicine so one might
reasonably ask whether there's any
difference between these I believe there
are some differences that I'm going to
and a bit of time talking about that
because I think it is important genomic
medicine which is primarily what I'm
doing includes traditional single gene
disorders or what we used to call
genetics or still call genetics for that
matter the analysis of the whole genome
which is genomics also analyses of
subsets of the whole genome which would
include the exome or the
pharmacogenomics family history which is
still even in the era of next-generation
sequencing is critically important in
terms of understanding and
contextualizing risk for an individual
patient development of a condition now
personalized medicine i went to the
definitive source of definitions
wikipedia and they define personalized
medicine as the use of information and
data from a patient's genotype or level
of gene expression to stratify disease
select a medication provide a therapy or
initiate a preventive measure that is
particularly suited to that patient at
the time of administration I think this
is a fine definition I think it's one
that many of my colleagues would promote
however I think it's dead wrong and it's
somewhat perhaps anachronistic for me as
a geneticist to promote a definition of
personalized medicine that doesn't
include any reference to genetics of
genomics but this definition from powder
and Casilla 1987 to me really sums up
what we're trying to do in personalized
medicine they in their article state
personalized medicine is the practice of
clinical decision making such that the
decisions made maximize the outcomes
that the patient most cares about and
minimizes those that the patient fears
the most on the basis of as much
knowledge about the individual status is
available I think this definition is
really important for two specific
reasons first of all not all patients
will have the same out
comes that they prioritize so take
example someone with stage four cancer
one individual may prefer a palliative
care pain control so that they can spend
the remaining time comfortable and
interacting with their family whereas
others may want every exploratory
investigator treatment that's possibly
available to them if we don't understand
the outcomes of the patient desires that
we really can't personalize their care
so this is really you know
person-centered patient-centered
medicine and then the second thing I
like about the definition is the last
statement as much knowledge about the
individual status is available so it
doesn't say that any certain types of
information like genomic information is
better than any other information
whatever information is necessary to
make decisions to achieve the outcomes
that are desired are relevant and so we
can't focus too much on one particular
type of knowledge now that being said
the term precision medicine more
recently has been emerging into use
although it actually has almost ten
years of use in certain circles I tend
to prefer the use percent of precision
medicine because clinicians have always
practiced personalized medicine and so I
would get tired of people saying when I
said we've got this new concept
personalized medicine saying well what
have I been doing all these years in
personalized medicine I said no it's
really that we've been practicing
intuitive medicine and what is meant by
that is that this is the care of
conditions that can be diagnosed only by
symptoms and only treated with therapies
whose efficacy is uncertain and watching
for an empiric response the reason why
the efficacy is uncertain is because our
interventions are tested on populations
and so therapies that move into practice
on balance have more people in the
population that have a proprietary
sponsor have an adverse event but for an
individual we can't determine a priori
weather
they're going to be a responder a non
responder or we'll have an adverse event
and that's why we have to wait for this
empiric response so essentially what
we've been doing is impure trial and
error and so in his book the innovators
prescription that disrupt a solution for
healthcare clay Christensen proposed the
idea of precision medicine which he
defines as the provision of care for
diseases that can be precisely diagnosed
whose causes are understood which
consequently can be treated with rules
based therapies that are predictably
effective and I think this is where we
really want to go with precision
medicine and I do expect that genomics
is going to play a key role in this and
I'll be able to illustrate this to some
degree later in the top now I want to
move to discussing the concept of value
as noted in the introduction we can
truly think of values or some
relationship between outcomes and the
cost of care and so if we think about
outcomes from the patient's perspective
which is what michael Porter's suggests
we have to do if we're considering value
is that there are medical or health
outcomes which is what is the response
to a treatment or a preventive strategy
how safe is the intervention that we're
doing there are also service outcomes
that are important to the patient how
many visits does it take to achieve a
given health outcome how much does this
disrupt my life routine how satisfied am
I with the care how empowered am I to
participate in my care there's also an
outcome that relates to the to
information how do we convey information
of importance to to patients now we've
tended to value this very highly in
genetics frankly because we haven't had
a whole lot of treatments that we've
been able to implement in the past but
it's been noted that this is very
difficult to value economically and we
have this tension between what we might
characterize his personal utility which
is this information is important for me
to make decision
versus that we just can't spend an
infinite amount amount of money on
health care so how much personal utility
or information can we afford in the
construct of health care costs that are
reaching their upper limits I think it's
also fair to say that in general we do a
very poor job of measuring the cost of
services I can frequently get an answer
when I say what does it cost to do this
but what is really being given to me as
what do we charge for it which is very
different from the cost so this is
another area that we have to pay
attention to now I try and think about
these things in a very simplistic way
and so I've constructed this 3 by 3
table where we can see on the top
there's cost of care which can decrease
it can be unchanged or it can increase
and then our medical and or service
outcomes can improve be unchanged or
they can worsen and so let's use some
genomic examples to kind of populate
this table so hla-b 5701 is a genotype
that puts individuals at very high risk
for developing a severe cutaneous
adverse event related to the use of the
back of your an antiretroviral
medication so if we test for this
particular genotype prior to the use of
the back of ear this is a very high
value test because it definitely
improves outcomes by avoiding these
severe adverse events and it decreases
the cost of care because we don't have
to pay for the medical care that would
be experienced in an individual were
they to have one of these exams now
another situation we frequently
encounter in healthcare is a new
treatment that is quite expensive but it
does improve outcomes so an example of
this is the drug imatinib which is treat
treatment for chronic myelogenous
leukemia prior to the development of
imatinib we had no treatments for CML so
when imatinib was introduced we've had a
treatment for an untreatable disease but
it's a very expensive medication but I
Society at least if we go by the
imperfect metric of coverage by
insurance companies has said that there
is sufficient improvement in health
outcomes to justify the increased costs
and care because payers are covering the
use of imatinib for chronic myelogenous
leukemia so not all improvements of
outcomes will come with a decreased or
unchanged cost and we just have to
balance the value that we're getting
based on the improving outcomes compared
to the increases cost now unfortunately
what we do a lot of unfortunately what
we do a lot of in health care apologize
for the little glitch with the server
there yes that we apply technologies
indiscriminately so there's another HLA
type 1500 1502 that is associated with a
increased risk of secured severe
cutaneous adverse events to patients
that are given carbamazepine this
particular HLA type is very prevalent in
Asian populations particular populations
that derived from the Han Chinese but
it's almost not seen in african-american
or Caucasian populations if we were to
decide to do population screening for
the fatal a type for every person in the
United States this would be a very poor
value it would inject a lot of cost I
say that health outcomes would worsen
because with low prevalence a lot of the
positive test would in fact be false
positives meaning that we would not be
giving appropriate therapies for
individuals who would benefit from the
use of a drug blood carbamazepine but
also there aren't that many people that
are exposed to carbamazepine so this
type of indiscriminate use of technology
can increase costs and worse and
outcomes and we want to try and avoid
this as best we can
but unfortunately with a lot of emerging
new technologies we do not think about
these types of issues and as a
consequence we end up getting a very
poor value now this is important because
if we look at value in the United States
here's a list of health care
expenditures per capita in a group of
piva developed countries and you can see
here that the United States is well
ahead of the rest of the developing
developed world in terms of how much
money we spend on health care per capita
now that may be a good thing if we had
superior outcomes the unfortunate thing
is that using some metrics that we think
would be relatively important which is
life expectancy infant mortality and
potential years of life lost the United
States ranks around 17th in these
metrics compared to other developed
countries where if you look at Japan
which has the lowest expenditure per
capita they in fact have outcomes that
are number one or number two and so
while we can argue how much money is
appropriate to spend in healthcare we're
not getting very good value than other
states for the money that we are
expending now it's important to note
that the ex the excess and money that
we're spending actually we can note that
spending in social determinants to
improve access to care and improve the
availability of health care and
preventive services which is built in
too many of our country's healthcare
systems is not something that is well
integrated in the United States and
sumit consequence the healthcare sector
end up bearing a lot of this burden so
that could be a whole talk in itself but
suffice it to say we have some work to
do now in genomics we have very little
information at the present time about
the value of this intervention in
traditional genetics we have the
challenge that we have a lot of
disorders that
are rare individually but are
collectively common when you aggregate
them together but the problem is is that
you have a very heterogeneous set of
outcomes for these various disorders but
rather than making that an apology the
reality is is that we've also not done
any concerted efforts to generate
evidence of benefit and that's something
that we must do because the healthcare
system is moving to a system of
value-based assess assessments and if we
as a field don't define value and
outcomes then fella will do that for us
so we have to determine how to assess
the value of genomic medicine and at
least from my perspective one of the
areas where there's some potential is
the fact that genomic information
germline genomic information doesn't
change over the course of a patient's
lifetime for all intents and purposes
and so there's the opportunity to reuse
this information over a lifetime so the
advantages of this is it spreads the
cost out over a lifetime of care which
avoids the need to do repeat testing
which could conceivably reduce a
duplication and waste having the
information available means it can be
used as soon as it's needed to make
healthcare decisions as opposed to
saying well I want to use this drug I
know there's a pharmacogenomic variants
it's important I have to send off the
test so I can't prescribe the drug
that's not something that works very
well in the health care sector and of
course as I alluded to earlier we could
potentially have much more precise
pharmacologic therapy and improve the
safety of medications as well as
choosing the best tolerated the most
effective therapy related to
pharmacogenomic determinants combined
with clinical determinants of drug
response and adverse events now there's
a lot of questions that go along with
whether or not we can do it where do we
store the information more importantly
how can we make sure that that
information is available wherever the
patient receives care in the United
States we do not have a national health
system we have a bunch of different
healthcare delivery areas and that
information
doesn't move well from one system to
another so that's a big problem and it's
a problem even in countries where this a
national health system right now we have
very little evidence of benefit or
evidence of things that don't work that
we shouldn't be doing until we have to
generate that evidence also our
knowledge of genomics right now is in
its early infancy and there's the vast
majority of the genome we have no idea
what it does and what impact that has on
health and so we have to have a way to
update this information over time we
must be able to present this information
when it's needed at the point of care so
that when a medical decision is being
made that that information is instantly
available we also have to recognize the
potential for discrimination that this
information could be used for negative
purposes there are some protections in
place in the United States about the
misuse of genetic information to
discriminate for health insurance and
for employment but for things like life
insurance and long-term disability there
are no protections at the present time
now I want to present value from rather
the national perspective to anticipate a
question that some of you may have which
is why would a healthcare system like
geisinger choose to invest in genomics
so this is a map of our healthcare
system for those of you who are familiar
with us geography we encompass most of
central Pennsylvania and we also now
have a healthcare system in atlantic
city new jersey and just to demonstrate
here this is where i am currently
residing Danville Pennsylvania which is
a ton of about 8,000 people that has a
healthcare system whose campus here
employees 14,000 so it's an interesting
model interesting place to practice and
the integration of our system provides
some interesting opportunities to study
value and we talked about the suite
which is where we think that partnership
with the clinical enterprise and
innovation can really play a huge role
so we have our clinic which is
represented by the bubble on the left
but we also own a pair the guys in your
health plan which pays for care we're
also an employer of about 30,000 people
and we serve as the payer for that group
as well so in common to these different
bubbles is are things like population
management our provider structure our
infrastructure and our electronic health
record and if we can find ways to align
objectives across these different areas
that's where we can really have the
greatest impact then is that the sweet
spot and so that's what we strive to do
so when we think about genomics we think
about how can we make this work within
our sweet spot now finally what you've
all been waiting for a discussion of our
genome first approach and genome first
is a different type of a paradigm where
the props for the clinical encounter is
a DNA variant usually in clinical
medicine the patient presents with a
sign or symptom or constellation of
signs and symptoms and then initiates
the diagnostic process and then we
generate testing as a result sometimes
genetic testing if it turns out to be
something that's relevant to genetics
but in this case what we're doing is
we're saying there's a variant in the
genome that we think puts an individual
at very high risk for developing a
condition that we can do something about
and as a consequence we will contact
that individual on the basis of the DNA
variant so genome first as opposed to
pay a fee gnome or sign and symptom
first approach now we can do this
because we are involved in a
collaborative project where we're moving
towards having approximately 250,000 of
our patients who will have exome
sequencing done this is being done in
the context of a large research project
and as part of that we are looking
through the victims to identify
individuals that have what we did
determine to be actionable results in
gene
that are part of the known genetic
conditions we take that data and then we
will return the result to patients and
their providers and in addition to that
we will support the patients and
providers with long-term follow-up
related to the results and he'll assist
with management planning so as part of
this we have to opera operationalize a
scalable return results infrastructure
within our integrated healthcare
delivery system so I had alluded to my
code earlier my code is a
community-based health initiative where
individuals are consented to participate
the consent consists of a broad consent
to research a collection of a specimen
in most cases just a blood specimen
where we extract DNA and then maintain
serum within the bio bank but then the
individuals will also consent to return
the results for medically actionable
indications and also for recontact for
specific research studies where we want
to get additional clinical information
this has been an extremely successful
program at guys in here and we have
about a ninety percent success rate when
we approach people to consent in the
project very high rates of buy-in from
the community at present we're
approaching a hundred and forty thousand
individuals who have been consented we
have specimens available on approaching
a hundred thousand and I've completed
exome sequencing on about 60,000
individuals we have a list currently of
76 genes that are inclusive of the
initial ACMG 56 gene list and this is
associated with 27 conditions we have
three top priority conditions that have
been identified as being the leading
candidates for public health
intervention or population health
intervention in genomics and that is
familial hypercholesterolemia Lynch
syndrome and hereditary breast and
ovarian cancer
as I mentioned our biorepository started
in 2007 it follows extensive
consultation with our patients and other
stakeholders and that really inform the
design of the project and we recently
defined it as the Community Health
Initiative to reflect the fact that we
can now use information derived from the
project as part of our population health
initiatives as I mentioned the geisinger
76 focuses on 27 conditions it builds on
the ACMG incidental finding list from
2013 these are heavily focused on cancer
predisposition genes such as brca1 and 2
cardiovascular disease including
familial hypercholesterolemia and
hypertrophic cardiomyopathy malignant
hyperthermia and a couple of rare
genetic disorders for which there are
good interventions hereditary
hemorrhagic telangiectasia and ornithine
transcarbamylase deficiency now as we
look at the information oh I should have
mentioned I apologize here this
publication in science from december of
last year provides details on this and
so i would recommend that for your
reading if you would like additional
information as i mentioned these three
conditions fh hereditary breast ovarian
cancer and Lynch syndrome are the top
priority conditions it turns out that
about 1 in 100 individuals have a
pathogenic or likely pathogenic variant
in one of these three genes alright I'm
sorry and one of these in genes in one
of these three conditions there are
multiple genes as noted here that can be
associated with the three conditions so
FH is associated with early onset
coronary artery disease and stroke and
we can utilize targeted screening and
aggressive medical management in
individuals with this condition
hereditary breast ovarian cancer
syndrome is amenable to targeted
screening and prophylactic medical and
surgical interventions so prophylactic
sectomy or helping to offer ectomy use
of hormone related therapies to reduce
risk can all be utilized and then Lynch
syndrome which is an early
predisposition to colorectal and uterine
cancers particularly for colorectal
cancer there's very effective screening
and management through the use of
colonoscopy which not only identifies
the precancerous lesions but removes
them now when we find out pathogenic or
likely pathogenic variant that initiates
a gene-specific evaluation that includes
a history which includes family history
as well an examination where relevant if
there are signs or symptoms that could
be looked for or found on physical
examination potentially additional
testing and in consultation with
specialties this is outlined and taken
from an article by Mike Murray in
genetics and medicine in August of 2016
and we recognize that there are going to
be five groups that could be identified
as a result of this particular approach
Group one is a group where when we
return the results they say yes and I'll
use an example of brca1 here we say we
found a variant in brca1 and they say
yes we knew that because I had a cancer
and my position thought that I could be
at risk I did clinical testing and we
found the same variant through clinical
testing so this is essentially
confirming the previous unit type and
phenotype that's been observed now
they're still value to this because what
we found is that even in these
individuals who have had clinical
testing they've not always been
appropriately informed about follow-up
that would be most appropriate and more
importantly that family members might be
at risk so we found some care gaps in
this group even though they already knew
they had to die
else's group too this is a group where
an individual has had a condition or
phenotype related to the genetic variant
so again using BRCA as an example an
individual with breast cancer but for
whatever reason they have not undergone
clinical testing perhaps they don't have
a family history that is suggested
perhaps they did but the family history
was not obtained or the clinician did
not actually recommend the testing in
this case we would say we now have an
explanation for why you develop the
condition that you develop and here are
some additional recommendations for your
care that should be done based on this
new information group 3 is a group of
individuals where at the time of the
return of results there is no evidence
of a clinical phenotype that has been
detected through routine medical care
but when we say there are certain
screening things that we would recommend
you do let's say mm ah mammogram for an
individual to BRC a variant we identify
an early breast cancer so this
individual impact have the condition had
a phenotype but did not know that they
had it because there were no clinical
symptoms that were noted and so we
really make an early diagnosis here
where hopefully we would be able to have
more effective therapies now there are
two groups that at the time of the
initial return of results do not have
any evidence of disease even when we do
the appropriate surveillance group for
would be one where over time as we do
the surveillance which again in BRCA
might be mammograms and breast MRI would
develop an early cancer over time and as
a consequence that would essentially
move them then into a group 3 group 5 is
the most problematic group weird what we
know we're going to be returning results
to individuals who will never develop
the condition for which they're at risk
because none of these conditions are
penetrant even in highly penetrant
families there may be twenty to thirty
percent of individuals to carry a BRCA
pathogenic variant who never developed a
cancer so we're going to be increasing
the intensity of medical care for these
individuals who will not have any
benefit from it because it would never
have developed a condition and so this
really is sort of a negative value now
we don't have a lot of choice right now
because we don't understand why these
individuals don't develop the problem it
may be that over time we will develop
information that would allow us to say
you know what you have this variant but
you're not going to dissolve the problem
therefore we don't need to do intensive
intervention for you but the other thing
to point out about the value proposition
is that when we consider the patient in
genetics or genomic it's not just the
patient but if that patients family and
so even though that index patient may
not develop a condition it is quite
possible the family members that carry
that pathogenic variant could develop
the condition and would achieve value
from the return of that result even
though the index case does not so this
is something that we're going to be
studying and collecting outcomes around
over time so we have to define the
outcomes and it's important when we
think about outcomes to define them from
the get-go so again what are the health
outcomes these will fall into three
different broad categories process
outcomes are ones that are the easiest
to measure if we recommend that an
individual we recommend that an
individual it's a mammogram or get a
lipid panel and they got it and so we
can check off the box yes they follow
that recommendation intermediate
outcomes are results that relate to the
health outcome of interest but are not a
health outcome in and of themselves the
best example here would be the LDL
cholesterol level in fh so if we do that
lipid level and we determined that the
LDL cholesterol is elevated that would
in
increased risk for cardiovascular
disease and we would have a target that
we could treat and so that's a very good
intermediate outcome because there's a
good chain of evidence that suggests
that if we use certain medications to
lower the LDL cholesterol that that will
reduce the health outcome of interest
which in this case would be
cardiovascular events and so that's a
typical health outcome but other health
outcomes could include breast cancer
ovarian cancer colorectal cancer etc we
also have a number of patient-centered
outcomes that would include satisfaction
patient engagement information as we
talked about earlier access to care and
how do you feel about yourself self
assess well-being which is actually a
very strong predictor of healthcare
utilization and then there are outcomes
from the system perspective what is the
cost that we incur by doing this what
are potentially avoided costs from
earlier intervention what impact does
this information have an overall
utilization how about patient experience
we are now being graded on what patients
think about our system and we have
reimbursement this tied to that could
this system decrease patient experience
which would cost us money and then
there's the marketing outcome that is
important for systems which is what how
does this impact our visibility with our
peers and our reputation so all of these
things have to be accounted for and
we're in the process of building out
ways to capture the different outcomes
for the conditions of interest now this
is a slide that identifies how we're
going to return these results so this
gives epping infrastructure issues that
I talked about before and I'm just going
to walk through this from top to bottom
so when we get a pathogenic variant that
passes our criteria for return that
result is an issue sent to the primary
care provider of the participant there
are five business days that are allowed
to go by after that time the clinical
genomics group sends a message to the
patient through the electronic health
record through the patient portal for
those patients who have a patient portal
account for those that don't we send a
letter and then we allow 5 to 10
business days before we would directly
contact the patient with a phone call
now it in many cases the primary care
provider in that first encounter will
take the initiative will contact the
participant and will schedule an
encounter either with themselves or
potentially in conjunction with the
genomic clinical genomics group and we
facilitate that scheduling that
appointment if we are unable to contact
the participant through any of these
methods then we send a letter registered
letter with the result to the patient
and we documented electronic health
records that we want unable to contact
the patient now we've had some
circumstances where we've had
participants contact us after receiving
the letter in which case then we do the
disclosure phone script and we also
start to take the family history and
provide an identifier to the family
history so that we can manage these
pedigrees we send the results of support
materials to the patient and then we
allow the participant to have their
follow-up with their primary care
provider with plenty of genomics or with
both and our clinical genomics group
assist with any referrals that are
necessary and ultimately when
recommendations are generated we work
with the primary care provider and
condition-specific specialists to make
sure that the recommendations are
clearly communicated to the participant
and then monitor to see whether the
recommendations are followed up on so we
want to close that loop and make sure
that information is actively worked on
apologize for the drink I have a bit of
a cold I'm starting to dry out this is
probably not well visible but you can
see that as of februari first we have
returned 241 results to two hundred and
thirty-nine patients there are two
unfortunate individuals who have
received two results as a part of this
but we post these publicly and so the
URL that's given on the slide will take
you directly to this page with it which
is updated on a monthly basis and you
can see on the left-hand column that we
have conditions so we have a reddit area
breast ovarian cancer which consists of
over half of the returns we've done so
far familial hypercholesterolemia etc
down the list to some of the rare
disorders so this is something that
again we want to make publicly available
and hope that our experience is able to
inform others that are interested in
moving into this area now I want to
provide some specific examples of how we
think this type of a genomic return of
results can really improve care I want
to focus on some work that we've been
doing in familial hypercholesterolemia
right now on our guides near 76 there
are three genes that are known to be
associated with FH LDL are the LDL
receptor is by far away the most common
a gene that's been identified in prior
studies but the genes April be and pcsk9
are also known to be associated with FH
in our population we find a prevalence
of these at approximately one in 200 and
as I mentioned the clinical risk here is
early onset coronary artery disease and
stroke and that we have very effective
management strategies related to
screening and medical management so this
is an overview from our 50,000 our first
analysis and so what we find here is
in just over 50,000 sequence
participants we identified 229
individuals with a pathogenic or likely
pathogenic variants and I should mention
we use very strict criteria for calling
out a variant this would be either start
or estar three level evidence in clinvar
or in the case of LDL are where loss of
function is the mechanism of action we
apply loss of function analysis to novel
variants it may not be reported in
databases as likely pathogenic or
pathogenic these variants also pass
through two levels of review by the
laboratory that is doing the
confirmatory testing and a CLIA
certified laboratory and also through
our own bioinformatics pipelines so two
independent sets of groups come to the
same conclusion that this is a
pathogenic or likely pathogenic variant
and you can see that the prevalence here
is about 1 and 222 and you can also see
that for the most part we've done
ascertained from general clinics however
we do have a subset that are coming out
of the cardiac catheterization lab and
as you would expect the prevalence in
the cardiac catheterization population
is a much higher about twice as high as
you would expect compared to other sites
now the interesting thing is when we
look at the prevalence of variants based
on the maximum documented LDL
cholesterol in the electronic health
record this is what I mean by this is in
lipid profiles if I'm individuals had
multiple lipid profiles we look at the
highest LDL cholesterol that is noted
you can see what you would expect to see
which is if you have a relatively low
LDL cholesterol less than 155 which is
the majority of the population
we see a prevalence of about one in six
hundred for pathogenic variants whereas
if you move to the other end LD across
hall civics that are extremely high
greater than 330 the problems here is
one in three so this is reassuring that
we're seeing exactly the sort of signal
that you would expect to see with
increasing LDL cholesterol but it is a
bit dismaying with individuals with this
high of an LDL we're only identifying
one and three who have pathogenic
variants so that means we have some work
to do in terms of our variant calling
and potentially identifying other genes
that might be involved in LDL
cholesterol metabolism now if we look at
our LDL range in fh very negative versus
fh variant positive in our population
you can see that there is considerable
overlap the blue which is the fh variant
positive clearly skewed to the right
with some individuals with
extraordinarily high LDL cholesterol but
you can note a huge area of overlap and
even individuals with f h+ variants can
sometimes have very low LDL cholesterol
some of these are in individuals that
are undergoing treatment but we found
significant numbers that have never had
a treatment that have LDL cholesterol
czar in the normal range which is
something that we'll talk about in just
a bit now it's important to recognize
that if we only use LDL as a criterion
for FH which is what is currently
recommended that it definitely increases
the false negative rate in adults and so
this is from a publication by star in
2008 and essentially you can see the
same type of pattern we're observing in
our families that in both of the
pediatric population and in the adult
population there are a significant
number of individuals with FH who have
normal LDL cholesterol levels and as a
consequence will not be identified and
this is a significant issue for reasons
that will discuss in just a bit this is
just one of the fh diagnostic criteria
the salmon Bruton criteria that in under
15 I give them LDL thresholds of 155 and
an LDL in adults of greater than 190 and
so this is the cutoff in children you
can see significant numbers of the fh
population below that cut off and then
again here in adults more than half of
adults are under that cut off so LDL by
itself is not nearly as sensitive as we
would like it to be again if we apply
these cut-offs in our population you see
exactly the same pattern now what's the
impact so this is from a publication in
the same issue of science that focused
on fh and what you can see from our
criterion when we mine our EHR data
looking for cardiovascular events
specifically coronary artery disease
that if you look at individual with a fh
variant compared to individuals out of
variant there is a very large signal
with a relative risk or operation rather
of 2.6 with a p-value that's
extraordinarily high and if we focus on
the most pathogenic variants which are
the loss of function LDL are variants
you can see here that the odds ratios is
five and a half now April be and pcsk9
are much less frequent which is why even
though we're detecting a signal the
confidence intervals are much broader
now what's interesting is if we look at
premature coronary artery disease is
defined by the American Heart
Association you can see that these odd
odds ratios go up so now if we look at
the loss of function for LDL are that
odds ratio was 10 * with a p-value of 10
to the minus 19 so this is a huge signal
of the importance of these fh variants
that we can determine out of our
population so that led us to evaluate
well how are these people being treated
are they being appropriately managed so
out of the 229 patients we identified
with one of these 35 areas 45 of them we
excluded because they had not had an LDL
cholesterol unless 14 within the last
five years now that doesn't mean they
didn't have an LDL cholesterol in the
last five years because it could have
occurred outside of the system in which
case we would not see that in our
electronic health record 14 of the
individuals had also died between the
time they enrolled in the program and
this analysis so ultimately we had a
hundred and seventy patients that we
analyzed the median age was 61 and a
half sixty one percent females and
ninety-six percent white this matches
our overall micro population to a tee so
it does not seem like we have ascertain
meant issues here one thing that's a
little bit unusual you'll notice that
even though I was saying that April be
was somewhat more of somewhat rarer than
LDL that we have about equal numbers
here and that reflects a family where we
have multiple members of the family that
are in our my code population that have
a familial April be variant so that
excuse this to some degree this is a
plot that looks at our current status
uses you can see that a third of these
individuals are not currently on statins
which is the first line recommended
therapy for individuals with FH now some
of these individuals had a record of
having been on the Staten in the past
but some of them are clearly not
adherent to them so about two-thirds are
on a statin therapy but if you notice
less than half are on high intensity
statins about twenty percent are on
moderate intensity stems that may or may
not be appropriate given the LDL control
and that this slide gets at that and
what you can see here is that as the LDL
cholesterol
goal is in an individual's FH is an LDL
cholesterol less than 100 what you can
see is only twenty one percent at least
based on the current study has a LVL of
less than 100 we do see a treatment
effect however because the sort of the
medium of the bell-shaped curve here is
skewed to the right in individuals when
you look at their lifetime max maximum
compared to individuals that are under
treatment where it's more towards the
left which is what we would hope to see
but you can see that there's a
substantial number of patients that are
not at the goal that we would like them
to have and this is why it's important
to identify individuals this is a study
by Cara at all from last year that shows
that even in individuals with FH who
have very low LDL cholesterol at
baseline they still have an increased
risk of cardiovascular events in fact
they have a than twice the risk compared
to the reference population and as you
move to the right the higher the LDL
cholesterol that larger the odds ratio
is with an odds ratio of almost 25 for
those individuals that carrie Ann fh
variant so what this is telling us is
that having an FA cherien even if you
have a normal LDL cholesterol confers
additional risk we think that this is
because of a lifetime exposure to
elevated levels of cholesterol but we do
not have confirmatory data at that time
but it does indicate that it is that
doing this type of a genome first
analysis to identify individuals with FH
has value over and above just measuring
a lil cholesterol so in summary about
fifty four percent of patients recent
LDL cholesterol go
of less than 100 at least once in their
lifetime 109 or about half the patients
had an LDL cholesterol record in the
last 12 months but that mean LDL
cholesterol was 134 which is
significantly above what we would want
to see so the conclusions that we can
draw from this initial data analysis is
that almost all carriers of an fh marion
were previously diagnosed with
hypercholesterolemia but that an EHR
review so the 30 these patients would
not have ever been diagnosed with FH
based on clinical criteria and that more
importantly many individuals remain
under treated and that half of our
patients have never achieved in LDL
cholesterol goal now one of the reasons
for this is that evidence is necessary
but not sufficient and they get them to
the implementation piece here so when we
think about fh we can't think about just
that individuals and sitting across from
us that individual exists within a
context of family members and other
caregivers and there's a team of
caregivers that surround these
individuals including their primary care
provider in the case of the project
we're talking about clinical genomics
cardiology may be involved ob/gyn
because if individuals aren't
cholesterol-lowering medications like
statins that has an impact if an
individual ones become pregnant because
statins can increase your risk for birth
defects dieticians are important and
pharmacists so what we're doing now is
to try and implement a approach to a
more integrated care that will empower
patients and allow us to achieve better
goals of related to treatment so again
the initiation here in the upper
left-hand corner is the identification
of a pathogenic barrier so we have that
pre visit which we discussed before but
now in the context of FH that initial
visit could consist of a visit either
with clinical genetics genetic
counseling primary care provider or some
combination of the two at that time we
would do a baseline assessment
a risk stratification and in conjunction
with the participants determine the
treatment gold we would then initiate
follow-up which in this clay case would
include something that we've developed
here at geisinger called medication
therapy disease management or MP p.m.
which is pharmacy lead care and we found
in other conditions including some lipid
opposite that having the pharmacist
leading the care team maximizes the
pharmacological management helps us to
better achieve goals and use a
laboratory test more appropriately so
it's been a very effective approach in
other settings that we are now going to
use in the setting of familial
hypercholesterolemia and we have other
team members that may be called in as
needed the dietitian the cardiologist
ob/gyn and additional risk assessment
and care the health outcomes that we're
looking at is we want to reduce the
incidence of cardiovascular events
that's what we want to give to we now
have a course robust intermediate
outcomes including our LDL cholesterol
levels where the goal is a target of
under 100 for most individuals except
for those that have had a history of a
cardiovascular event in which case we
treat to a more aggressive target of 70
and we want to have process measures
which include are we utilizing
appropriate pharmacologic therapy are we
doing appropriate laboratory testing now
I want to conclude by returning to that
face of our project to put really a
story around what I've just described in
a theoretical term this individual as
part of the my code project was found to
have a pathogenic variant in brca1 we
returned that result and because she had
not had a mammogram for five years she
had a mammogram which was normal she was
counseled per guidelines the NCCN
guidelines were using for BRCA
management include an annual mammogram
and breast MRI alternating every six
months
consideration of risk reducing
mastectomy and tell pingu oophorectomy
clinical breast exams periodically
encouragement of breast awareness and
then the consideration of Risk Reduction
agents and investigational imaging and
so all of this was returned and after
several months the patient returned to
the clinic and said you know after
thinking about it I'm the primary care
person for my grandchildren I need to be
around for my grandchildren so I would
like to move forward with a prophylactic
helping Lula for ectomy so this was
scheduled and she had this procedure
done in August of 2016 there were no
complications from the surgery but as
part of the guidelines serial sectioning
of the fallopian tubes and ovaries was
done and in the right fallopian tube it
was noted that she had a high-grade
serous carcinoma there was one point
four centimeters and there was evidence
of stromal invasion it's important to
note that we had done a pre-surgical
ultrasound that did not see this and
that this patient ca125 was normal and
this illustrates the fact that for
prophylaxis of our surveillance for
ovarian cancer our tools right now are
really not up to speed up elva quashing
was also positive and this would stage
the tumor at either a1c although there
was the potential to upstage into a to
see because of the pathology of the
tumor this individual in was started on
chemotherapy less than a month later
with a combination of carboplatin and
Paxil unfortunately as you'll recall she
also had Crohn's disease and because of
that she had been on a minute of
suppression and we needed to just
discontinued that because of the cancer
risk which now superseded the risk of
the Crohn's disease the guidelines
recommend that this can be restarted two
years post-treatment but unfortunately
the patient had a flare of Crohn's
disease which has been significant and
so this is something that from a
personalized perspective
trying to balance the management but I
think it's very important to note that
the improvement or five-year survival
for stage 1 ovarian cancer is
eighty-nine percent stage to the
sixty-six percent if you move into
stage-three now you're dropping into the
twenty percent or less range for
survival so we think that this detection
is likely going to confer a survival
benefit on this individual related to
the disease so in conclusion genomics is
an emerging technology we have to be
able to demonstrate improved value in
our current delivery settings before it
will be adopted but as I think I've
Illustrated implementation is very
complex and it requires a systematic
approach of engagement education
evidence and evaluation outcomes must be
defined and systems must be built to
support the measurement of these
outcomes to determine which services
really add value so that we can
emphasize those and remove services that
do not add value and ultimately we can't
forget the idea that the people that we
care for our the most important and we
must consider the value from the
perspective of the patient with that I
would end and would like to thank all of
our my code participants which I
mentioned now is approaching 140,000
guiding our patients our collaborators
for the discovery HR project which
includes researchers at regeneron
pharmaceuticals and the geisinger the
information that I presented as part of
the study today reflects contributions
from both groups of authors and that I
also like to thank my colleague dr.
Michael Murray for use of some of the
slides that he has developed with that
all end and we can open the talk for
questions
thank you dr. Williams before your
informative presentation before we pop
into the Q&A section I just want to let
everyone know a reminder for our
audience on how to submit questions
simply simply type it in the Q&A box
found by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window dr. Williams will
answer as many questions as time permits
okay receive the first question is how
have guides irritations reacted to read
to this return of genomic results
Thanks that's an excellent question our
patients so far have been for the most
part positive about the return results
we were concerned that they might not
have remembered that they had consented
for returning results but most of them
did recall that was part of the process
we've had only a couple that have
declined to have their results returned
I think a lot of the reason is we spent
a tremendous amount of time before we
started the program engaging with
potential participants and trying to
understand from their perspective what
they were interested in what they wanted
and so as we constructed the project we
were able to incorporate what they
wanted into the structure and as a
consequence the acceptance system good
now that is something that we are
tracking as part of our outcomes
measures the service outcomes and we are
going to be continuously improving how
we're doing it to meet the needs of our
participants so we hope that this early
positivity will continue as we go
forward
excellent thank you so much for your
answer our second question of the day
asks how are you contacting family
members for kaskade testing thank you
that's an excellent question again this
is going to be a us-centric answer in
the United States we have certain
restrictions in terms of how we can
communicate information and so the
present time the standard of practice in
genetics for contacting at-risk family
members is to go through the index case
which would in this case be the my code
participant provide them with
information that they can give to their
family members and then provide contact
so that the family members can contact
us directly or if they're not in our
area we can work with them to identify
genetic providers in their area now that
works well in theory but in practice not
all families get along all that well and
so we have unfortunately encountered
situations where you know someone would
say well I'm going to let my sister know
but I'll be darned if I'm going to let
my brother know this is not an ideal
outcome and so one of the things that
we're looking at is whether or not there
would be a certain circumstances where a
family member is really not acting in
the best interest of an at-risk family
member where we might be permitted to
directly contact that individual about
potential risk this is a completely new
area it's not been explored we have some
experts in our research group in ethical
and legal issues and so we're hoping
that we can plow some new ground here
and identify better ways that we can
facilitate the communication we do
provide the the index cases with
information that they can distribute to
their
only members in multiple copies to try
and lower the burden of them having to
describe what's going on so so far the
systems worked reasonably well with that
caveat thank you dr. Williams for your
answer we are running short on time
today so it looks like one of time for
one additional question what types of
resources are available for participants
to want to have a result returned in
addition to what I've already described
we are working on a novel approach to
develop what we're calling a patient
facing genomic test report so this is
not a laboratory report but it's a
report that is available to the patient
either in printed form or ideally
through the electronic health record
patient portal that provides information
about their result and has links to
resources through URLs so they can go to
pair patient support groups or to
information resources from places like
the national library of medicine etc and
those reports are paired with the report
that's designed for the provider and
they are they are paired together we
have shown in some earlier studies that
this enhances communication the design
of these reports was led by our patients
and our providers so rather than not
saying well this is the report we're
going to use we let them design the
report and so we're looking to use this
broadly within our return results
project and we think that this may be a
way to provide information back to
patients in systems where they may not
have the genetics expertise that we're
lucky to have a geyser
I would like to once again thank dr.
Williams for his presentation dr.
Williams do you have any final comments
you would like to leave us today once
again just thank you very much for the
opportunity to present I know that we
ran short of time for questions I
believe the organizers will be
forwarding written questions to me I
will get to answering them it may take
me a bit but I will commit to answering
all of the questions and I hope that as
we move forward in the field of genomics
that more and more of us will be able to
move into implementing and I hope that
at least some of the information that I
provided today will give you some ideas
about how this might work in your
respective organization so best of luck
to you in this to our audience if we
have not answered your if your question
was not answered say please know that
yet your question will be answered it is
a lot email additionally I'd like to
thank the audience for joining us today
and thank ladder is for today's
educational webcast this webcast can be
viewed on the nance room a 20-17 Lavery
flora we're using email what it is
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
this is Christina firm labyrinth and we
have to see you here next time at
leverage com goodbye
you